here's a report from wsb in atlanta
about actual racial segregation in a
public school in the city this is the
local news report uh it's a little bit
long it's a couple minutes but i think
it's worth watching also when we play
long clips it gives me a chance to drink
coffee that's the real reason we do this
but let's watch this go ahead
we've lost sleep
trying to figure out like why would a
person do this
kyla posey says she was stunned when she
learned about classes segregated by race
at maryland elementary last year a
practice she says was put in place and
condoned by principal sharon briscoe
first
it was
just disbelief that i was having this
conversation in 2020 with
a person that looks just like me a black
woman it's segregating classrooms you
cannot segregate classrooms it's
you can't deal with it posey says she
found out the school was putting black
students in two separate classes with
two separate teachers the white kids
were placed in six classes with six
different teachers the parent says she
found this out when she let briscoe know
she wanted her child placed in the
classroom of a teacher she thought would
be a good fit posey says the principal
said that wouldn't work she said that
that's not one of the black classes and
i immediately said what does that mean
i was confused
i asked for more clarification
i was like we have those in the school
and she proceeded to say that yes i have
decided that
i'm going to place all of the
black students in two classes posey says
she insisted her child be placed in a
class with white students she says
briscoe explained her child would be
isolated and i explained to her she
shouldn't be isolated or punished
because i'm unwilling to go along with
your illegal and unethical practice
the poses recorded a call with an
assistant principal where they
complained about the segregated classes
the administrator confirmed it was the
principal's decision and seemed to offer
an explanation why the classes were set
up this way
we have more black kids too
and then some of them are in a class
because of the services that they need
uh
we'd like to say that this is shocking
actual racial segregation in the
classroom it's about the most illegal
thing
the most one of those fundamentally
illegal things a school could possibly
do
is uh to racially segregate their
classrooms
and actually call them there was no
attempt to hide it it wasn't like they
came up with different labels for this
and oh it just so happens
that it worked out racially in this way
no it's like that's our black class and
this is our white class right
um
we'd like to call that shocking i don't
think we really can i mean we have gone
full circle
and
we're back to this now
racial segregation sort of approached
from the opposite direction now though
um
where now it's a matter of we're going
to segregate because we're trying to get
the white kids away
racial segregation in the jim crow era
was the other way
we don't we don't want we don't want the
white people to have to deal with the
black people so we're gonna put them
over there
now it's just that in the reverse
and i say reverse which isn't to say
that it's reverse racism because of
course there's only one kind of racism
if you're
a person and you and you uh think the
people of another race are inferior
and then that makes you racist no matter
what race you are
but this is the reverse approach to
racial segregation reverse from what it
was
you know 100 years ago
um
and
so that that's not a surprise this is
the direction we've been headed
they've been doing this kind of thing in
universities and in college
colleges for a while now
maybe not that
explicit like we're gonna have a white
class in black class but
but we're gonna have a black only space
where but you know black people can get
together or people of color by poc can
all get together and we don't want white
people intruding on space we've been
doing stuff like that in colleges for a
while now
so this is where it's headed the if
there's anything sort of surprising here
um
it's that the principal
again made no no attempt to hide it
and so she assumed that everybody was
okay with it
the mother talking to the principal and
the principal says oh yeah it's our
black class
and the mother has to say
what what
the what now
my black class what's the problem with
that
and based on this report now maybe there
were other parents who were upset but it
it if if there were
it's they seem to be in the minority
it's mainly this mother who's objecting
which means either
the other parents didn't care and were
on board with it or they never heard
about it
i don't know which would be more
disturbing there could be some
combination of the two
that tells you something about public
school that's why i'm always harping on
this you send your kid into a government
building for seven eight hours a day
you're not gonna know everything that
you're not gonna know almost anything
that happens you're only gonna know what
your kid tells you and especially when
they're younger they're not gonna tell
you a whole hell of a lot
i get home from school and i i get home
from work
and i sit down with my kids i always ask
them
what you do today how'd it go like i
want to hear about their day
and uh they they never have a whole lot
to say like they'll they'll home in on
one little detail
like yesterday i came home i asked them
how to go today and the only thing they
told them they're very excited to tell
me but the only thing they told me about
was that they found uh a deer skull
in uh in a creek near our house which is
very exciting for kids i i don't i don't
blame it but that's the only event from
the day and everything was about the
deer skull
for kid that's the only thing that
matters right
so when i hear from parents and they say
oh you know as long as you're in in a
conversation with your kids and you have
an open line of dialogue you don't have
to worry about it because they're going
to tell you what's going on and
no they're not
when they're very young they're not
going to
the things that you know are important
and that you'd like to hear about they
don't know that that's important
i think the kids who are racially
segregated they don't understand they
don't know the history of this
of racial segregation in the school they
don't see a problem with it they might
not even told their parents
so the things that you know are
important your kids don't know that so
they might not tell you
and then as kids get a little bit older
and even if they do know that
something's important they might not
want to tell you
because they don't want you causing a
stink about it and all these other
things
and also they're being conditioned by
the school to think that these things
are okay
so you can't rely on that
another argument for well it's an
argument for homeschooling as always
also an argument for for uh for
cameras in the classroom
so that you could actually see that
happen when they segregate the
classrooms by race
[Music]
as we come full circle back to racial
segregation well i hope you enjoyed that
clip from the matt wall show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content